people mock Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg
for his BOTS like demeanor and
appearance but how would you react to
this in your ongoing dinner parties with
far-right figures some of who advanced
the conspiracy theory that white
supremacy is a hoax did you discuss
so-called social media bias against
conservatives and do you believe there
is a bias congresswoman I don't remember
everything that was in the Senate in
that course all right I'll move on can
you explain why you've named the Daily
Caller
a publication white well documented with
ties to white supremacists as an
official fact checker for facebook
congresswoman sure we actually don't
appoint the independent fact checkers
they go through an independent
organization called the independent
fact-checking network that has a
rigorous standard for who they allow to
to serve as a fact checker what a
contrast between showboating for cliques
and basic politeness at least Facebook's
AI has some I remember well Zuckerberg
created a company that employs thousands
a assi prevented Amazon from employing
thousands in a city that she represents
Zuckerberg big question is how do I
connect a billion people
hers is how did i do on TV it gets worse
it's almost like you think this is a
joke when you have ruined the lives of
many people discriminated against them
do you know what percentage of
african-americans are on Facebook in
comparison to majority folks do you know
what the percentages are people using
the Facebook yes do you know what the
percentages are for african-americans I
don't because we don't collect the
racism well it it came out in a report
and in the Pew Research Center that was
sent to you so maybe you just don't read
a lot of things that deal with civil
rights or african-americans so where are
all the fat checkers in this the
journalistic showboats
holding these politicians accountable
when they create phony smears I guess
brian Stelter is busy spell-checking
Trump's tweets my favorite take it away
al are there any members of the LGBT
U+ community associated with this
association mr. Zuckerberg congressman I
I don't know the answer who can
acknowledge that many people who
acknowledge that they are a part of the
community sorry not you do not know Wow
Zuckerberg doesn't know how many gay
people work on an idea that's a huge
problem
so after this show we're gonna get the
whole five staff together and then we're
gonna ask them if they like men women
are both because yeah I think that's
totally legal fact is nobody in that
room will ever do more to help more
people than the geeky guy they slimed
with idiotic questions it's pure
scapegoating still unable to accept
blame for 2016 they find a sacrificial
pinata and beat the stuffing out of it
in their home turf where they hold the
gavels they made Zuck into a straw man
and set fire to him I have no idea what
Zuckerberg politics are but after that
hearing I know what they should be he
should despise big government and its
enablers you should cling to free
markets and free minds and never take
these clowns seriously again maybe he
should stop being so polite they want to
destroy you mark next time DC comes
calling let it go to voicemail so Dana
what do you grab me great great his
performance with it I mean handling it
that calmly Wood faced with like
arrogance is pretending you know
something that you know nothing about
and that was a lot of arrogance and it
went on for hours and hours and he never
lost his cool and he I think that he is
so exceedingly cautious with his words
because one he doesn't want to offend
people right he also recognizes that he
he serves a bill to billion customers -
dude there are 2 billion people on
Facebook those people that are family
and friends people running businesses
people doing news all sorts of different
things and anything that he says can
move a market yeah in a second right he
talked about losing billion a hundred
billion dollars in one day when they
move to the news tab but that was the
right thing to do when you ask him if
he'll be polite in the future so
Washington there are several
factors coming together one of them is
the anti trust factor with some people
on Republicans and Democrats saying it's
a monopoly and should be broken up right
you have to ask yourself do you think
Washington can handle things better than
a private company God not after seeing
that one
how can she ask him or say with a plane
you know face you've destroyed the lives
of African Americans how would you say
that well but I think it's Bernice King
who was dr. King's daughter earlier this
week after Zuckerberg spoke at
Georgetown and he cited dr. King and
said you know well he'd want minority
opinions represented she said hey you
know what it was political
disinformation that led to his
assassinations it's true I think that a
lot of people would have problems here's
the thing destroyed the live here that's
what well here's what I think right I
find this very curious that
conservatives for most of Facebook's
life have said oh you guys are biased
against conservative content but now all
of a sudden they're defending Zuckerberg
why is that because he will let Trump do
whatever he wants he will not check
political lies on political ads and he
says it's freezing meat issue
the simple solution I've said this
before why is he taking political ads if
he doesn't want to stop the lies and the
hatred on Facebook he should say look
like I don't need political minorities
no it's not X each X facts on other ads
but he won't check them on political ads
and it's a gift to Trump you think
Zuckerberg though is supposed to sit
there now and look through every
political ad what seems as bias isn't
going to be at all subjective
what's dmoz in corrected from I mean AOC
is talking about this topic look at our
whole Twitter feed it's full of a bunch
of nonsense a bunch of and he's being
defended one because this is harassment
this guy went in there to answer some
questions and he got abused and he got
harassed believes and they're asking if
he's good if he knows the race and
sexual orientations of all the B's like
he or it should be
is that so he should be happy or sorry
in America
they know you don't talk to people
you're working with Jesse you don't go
like you don't talk to your staff go so
I need to know your sexual orientation
that is veronik yeah lose your job yes I
do want to talk to you about you bumping
the break well I haven't made up my mind
yet I'm working you know I'm LGBTQ are
XY and Z sometimes why
what was the poloidal and the Trump
pushed out on Facebook that was filled
with lies gosh I could yeah I could
stack them up they're so hot lately it's
all about impeachment okay I'm across
what are conducting on a legal process
it's an institution that's in the
Constitution okay so saying that
impeachment is unconstitutional that is
a lie and that should not get that's an
opinion because what an opinion one the
way he thinks is unconstitutional no
he's doing that to stirrup is based with
live great my point is Greg is that to
me who cares that line opinion puts out
an ad says the earth is going to die in
12 years if I can't substantiate it get
it out but I don't know what you can
supply it s'more of a line to say we're
going to die until you guys are jumping
now because you know alright that's a